سيطاه حسين الرئيس اردوغان ختم
حملته الانتخابيه في الجوله الاولى
بزياره جامعه اي صوفيا والصلاه فيها اليوم
في ختام هذه الحمله الانتخابيه في الجوله
الثانيه زار ضريحي من دريس واربكان ما هي
الرسائل التي يريدها الرئيس اردوغان من
رمزيه هذه الزيارات
[موسيقى]
الى الموضوع من الناحيه الرمزيه فان
مسجد
السلطان ايوب هو في واقي الامر مسجد كان
يزوره كل سلطان العثماني عندما يعتلي
العرش لذلك لهذا المسجد رمزيه خاصه
ثم كما تعلمون ان مسجد اي صوفيا ومسجد
السليمانيه وكذلك مساجد اخرى موجوده
ومعروفه واعتقد ان الرئيس اردوغان هذه
المره قد اختار مسجد السلطان ايوب
وبما ان النتائج الانتخابات لم تعلن بعد
ولم تحسن ولا نستطيع ان نقول ان زيارته
للمسجد كان الاعتدائه المنصب والعرش ولكن
زيارته لضريح عدنان
وكذلك
لضريح اربكان كان هو وفاء ايضا لهما
تاكيدا ايضا على
معاناتهم ربما واستشعارنا بذلك والرئيس
اردوغان يقومه نعم بمثل هذه الزيارات
للاطرحه والمساجد بين وقت واخر وخاصه هذا
ما رايناه ايضا في المحاوله الانقلابيه
يوم 15
وكذلك راينا زياراته بعد اخماد هذه
المحاوله
نعم الانقلابيه واذا ما اردنا ان نؤوله
نكون نعم انها هي عاده تاريخيه لقاده
وسلاطين الدوله ولكن بما ان النتائج غير
محسومه حتى الان قد لا نؤول بهذه الطريقه
ايضا